hey what's up my name's samuel lee's i'm
standing with my good friend mr crept
what's happening brother what's good we
are here in
pool in liverpool you've come from
london yeah how much can you buy houses
for around this area
43 grand meat no you can buy them for 43
grand
most people have to pay about 100 110
000 pounds literally you just negotiated
this for
43 000 pounds yeah refurbed it we're
gonna go through the full figures
you're the man property investment king
not just a rapper
not just a philanthropist come on show
us around bro all right cool with that
we've done a little bit of
um touch ups on the front it was a bit
we needed a little bit of sprucing a bit
that's an understatement a little bit
sprucing
a little bit sprucing new doors and all
that
have another look oh yes
fresh fresh fresh fresh dude this house
is fresher than your jacket bro
nice gray carpets love it dude did a
crappy job
yeah refurb is high standard lounge
looks banging
so when you bought it for 43 grand did
it look like this
nope it looked unrecognizable yeah like
it was
yeah but when you look at the property
in that fashion it's like
we see exactly right profit yeah in fact
i remember do you remember when i
was sat i was sat on a toilet right here
santa told him right here yeah so what
tom tommy put me through what did you do
here
yeah so here the kitchen came up to
about here yeah
and there was a toilet here so you have
to walk through the kitchen
get to the back of the toilet and you
know before
let's take out the toilet and extend the
kitchen and make the kitchen a bit
bigger
especially if we're doing it you know
hmo different people in here
big kitchen so where's the bathroom
going
upstairs upstairs okay and it's makes
sense
most important room in the house is the
kitchen yeah it is well
you want drivers yeah drivers here yeah
so you bought it for 43
the refurb in total how much was the
entire refurb
uh thirty thousand thirty thousand yeah
came on budget
came up i think just slightly slightly
under budget respect
good stuff and now the new value
so you in total all in stamp duty refurb
purchase price how much you're talking
75 75 all in
cash where'd you get the money um
if i tell you how to kill yourself
so you're making like fast pound with
your music yeah
making making good money you're pretty
good at what you do i've seen you in
concert
pretty right
[Applause]
all right so so made money in music
put it into properties strategically
bought the house 43
push the value up what's the value now
new valuations 110
110 000 so now you're putting all your
money out refinancing it i'm bringing
this bad boy out
exactly effectively
oh yeah show me the range
nice man nice orange feature wall nice
give give the room a better character
yeah yeah yeah so
why why did you choose to con like the
colors and stuff
what was the rationale behind that
that's real like it it gives it
the the house a bit of personality and
yeah just come to that i don't want the
orange room or the green room
right it kind of makes it pop individual
exactly
cool so where's this person they got you
got an ensuite right
obviously in here as well so with the
self turning on lights
shower self turning on lights all that
jazz the builders didn't want to
actually put a lot on screen here
um because they're piping and where it
was but
you know where there's a wheel there's a
way yes
and what was what was the why um
sani fleur turned it sunny flow toilets
which actually you know it's really
funny because sunny floor toilets 10 12
years ago used to really be bad
but these something they're not that bad
like you can flush them they're making a
little bit of a noise
but but see the little er
get used to that but in 10 seconds it
will start whereas
santa fe taurus 10 years ago it would
make that noise for like five minutes
now it's finished so not too bad
quite work goes up straight through to
the back of the house
as long as you don't put like nappies or
anything down there yeah literally
should be fine so how much is this room
renting out for
um around 375
375 okay okay not bad
come on now let's see the room so with
this property we've got three tenants
moving in next week yes um
but then the rents are like between 350
and 400 and there's three rooms so in
total how much rent you're going to get
um just under 1200 okay how much
cash flow profit is that going to give
you after all expenses
um about five to six hundred quid so
you're gonna make about five or six
hundred pounds a month
profit profit ongoing but you've pulled
all your money
out so yes all of my money that i
invested
yeah pulled out so effectively it's a
free house
and you're making about 600 pounds a
month for it and you've got all your
money back
nice all right max upstairs i love the
fact that you've gone with self turning
on lights because it just means that the
tenants forget to turn off the lights
it will just do it for another
don't call you the goat for nothing is
you bought this
property about six months ago just
before
they brought in articles
so next week when your tenants move in
what's happening next
month in june uh next month yeah when
you bring in oracle
there's not going to be no more hmos
we've got a unicorn now because
you can't do this anymore so this house
becomes a special edition house
which means the value's going to shoot
up the rents are going to shoot up
and you're just going to keep getting
paid and you put all your money out
anyway so
smart the blue room
is that blue or is it like gray oh blue
blue yeah
bluey grey grey yeah nice
i actually actually think this is the
best room this is getting this is
getting the most rent was it this is 395
and it's got a big bath in there what
was this remember when we came to this
property about six weeks ago
what did this look like and what
happened this basically
this was a corridor that led to the
toilet
and then this was like a tiny
what's it been like working with me
brother oh bro it's been a
uh honor to work with you though
just to even do this with you respect my
guy this is the man the goat the legend
no this is the man
appreciate your brother
you